dis donc robert quand tu étais petit la
confession t'as pas mal donné non quand
même oui j'ai cru à ça moi mais ma tête
j'y retournerais cette année il paraît
que depuis deux jours ces défunts dont
on peut le dire ma file au lieu de mon
père me plaît davantage et donc c'est
pour gagner ton paradis qui a fait une
chanson dédiée à jean paul 2 qui
s'appelle pape music
non mais c'est parce que j'avais été
bouleversée fier par le fait que le
pineau qui était puisque je fais pas de
l'humour qui étaient rentrés par son
abri il était vraiment sorti par le trou
de balle et jouent avec servilité d'être
immortalisés sinon ça c'est un
personnage comme on dit que je trouve
relativement sympa parce que même si
inventorié ils répètent des bonnes
choses mais aussi tant d'amour oui mais
vous par contre hull 6 c'était moins fan
tu raconte que ta mère tu l'a amené à
rome on va voir le pape way est qu en
fait contrairement à ce qui s'est passé
avec beaucoup de gens quand est arrivée
la balle a perdu la foi compter les
commerces
quand elle a vu que pas seulement
l'élévation c'est josé des photos du
pape au lieu de baisser la tête
elle a perdu la foi ma mère avait récité
le chapelet toute sa vie et est
pratiquante ah là là là mais ce non
seulement dimanche mais quelquefois la
fcc du premier m'enchantait très mal
shooté flatté je n'ai pas tellement
savoie et deuxio ce que ma mère qui
cherchait le bon dieu n'a vu que des
flashes de kodak et que des ornements en
or
elle s'est évanouie et depuis que je
n'ai amené au vatican à rome et n'a
jamais pu remettre les pieds dans une
église catholique
je sais que je fais de la peine à des
gens qui croient à quelque chose mais
demander la vérité mon pain vous l'avez
tu vois que le réveillon peu le doute à
main je crois que leur ai trouvé
sympathique mais c'est en même temps un
symbole d'une espèce de paralysie
tall emparé de l'univers sauf que mieux
vaut voir des gens suivent
idolâtré quelqu'un comme jean paul 2 ou
que dès que des méchants que son
équivalent en noir qui mettrait des
ondes négatives donc c'est quelqu'un je
discute pas pourtant toi tu t'es pas
mariés à l'église
tu t'es mariés dans une chapelle qui
ciabrini chapelle blanche à las vegas
avec l'espace non mais je me suis mariée
à las vegas c'est un mariage valide
parce qu'on voit quand même à l'hôtel de
ville on donne notre notre état civil et
tout çà et là le le pasteur m'a demandé
vous voulez vous de la musique en boîte
ou de la vrai j'ai dit je veux pas de
musée que ça me rappelle mon bureau mon
travail tout seul ensuite il nous a
mariés sature exactement trois minutes
et demie après ça nous a donné quatre
rouleaux de 25 sous pour aller jouer au
lady luck
mais il y en a eu de loi une pizza et
puis il ya place à du champagne l'état
du bébé doc ça c'était une des grandes
déceptions de mon mariage ma femme était
malade
est ce que tu es favorable sexualité
hors mariage au mariage ce que tu
trouves ton ferme ou non parce que j'ai
l'avantagé d'avoir épousé une femme bien
vous dise qui est obsédé sexuel comme
moi lorrain pas de danger que ça valait
la peine de mort mais vous peine de mort
je trouve qu'on devrait choisir mais
quand quelques la demande la peine de
mort devrait lui donner parce qu'à être
25 ans d'aléas les barreaux ou bien tu
mens ça doit être les pionniers devrait
avoir le choix
est ce que tu fais avant de légalisation
des drogues douces et oui comme
l'égalisation du porno ça disent des
choses que moins on a enfin comment dit
on a mis les qu'on n'a pas de ces choses
là mais plus c'est légal
et moins on a en parlé moins on a envie
d'être d'en consommer parce que ce qui
était formidable
les années 60 avec les drogues douces
c'est que c'est interdit ça fait un
petit bout ou telle évolution a su tout
le monde en a autant que tout d'abord
mais en grand prince et tout ce qui est
fumasse bhl abîme les poumons et donne
un cancer du poumon
donc mieux vaut boire de la bière
blanche que de fumer quoi que ce soit tu
fumes putois où je fume eu un peu de
nicotine ou un bon joint de temps en
temps mais il soit très très très très
bon parce qu'il ya des clous là dedans
c'est comme lorsqu'on me demande si tu
crois en dieu tu dis je sais pas je me
demande si si c'est pas une réminiscence
de mots l'éducation quand je dis mon
dieu aidez moi tu te demandes si c'est
pas finalement ton éducation qui t'a
marqué tu sais pas si tu prends de bain
je suis un stoïcien château et seront
visionnés s'attarder de gauche mais
surtout que l'unité est en ce sens que
j'aime adoré la nature les poissons
le soleil la lune se trouve que ça c'est
ça qui me enfin qui m'inspire qui mêlait
vers le haut qui m'inspire la beauté
mais mon idée de dieu c'est la relation
l'interrelation qu'il y entre les ags de
l'infiniment petit à l'infiniment grand
mais cette espèce de 2 ou alors je peux
pas le définir mux le l'interrelation
interactions ses sauts dieu pour moi il
le dit appuie croix non je voulais aller
en enfer la semaine dernière mais il
paraît que ça à penser au feu on peut
plier les personnes tu veux toujours
être enterré dans ton pialoux banon j'ai
déjà un pied dans la bien il faut de la
fois déconner et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de nos latitudes abonnez vous
il m'était impossible ou